welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka death Vader and
with the rise of Skywalker now up for
release the Star Wars sequel trilogy has
come to an end
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the movie and giving our
theories on some of the things that
leaves unexplained we'll also be
discussing the ending our thoughts on
the film overall and whether it's worth
going to see so if you want to know if
this movie is the chosen one or if it
ends up going to the dark side then this
is the video for you that will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to watch the rise of Skywalker
yet and don't want to know what happens
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video now let's get into our breakdown
of Star Wars the rise of Skywalker
okay so the rise of Skywalker it
basically revolves around several
MacGuffins in order to drive the plot
it's a MacGuffin Russian doll and the
opening of the movie centers around kylo
Ren searching for a device known as the
wayfinder that will guide whoever has it
to a sith palace on exit goal I don't
really know if it's a palace but it has
it their own subjects cavalry and almost
a kingdom like ascetic kylo finds it
during the introductory scene and
travels to EXA goal in a moment that was
shown heavily in last week's TV spot
upon arriving there not only does the
character discover that Supreme Leader
Snoke was a clone but he also comes
across Darth Sidious
or rather Emperor Palpatine who has been
reduced to a frail and weak old man now
the film doesn't ever explain how
Palpatine survived the destruction of
the Death Star however if you cast your
mind back to Revenge of the Sith you'll
remember that Palpatine discussed with
Anakin that there was a Dark Lord known
as Darth Plagueis who had a special
ability actually not now we're on the
subject have I ever told you the story
of Darth Plagueis the wise well he could
control the midi-chlorians to create
both life and even avoid death and
personally I think that this is the
method that Palpatine used for his
resurrection when talking about this he
gives a little nod to the line that some
considered the methods are natural which
is the same thing that the character
utters in the scene during Revenge of
the Sith we also discover in the film
that Palpatine is Reis grandfather and I
doubt that he was getting it on it due
to his pasty looking but head so he
likely created her father and then after
turning his back on destiny the
character went onto father Rey Star Wars
has a big motif in the law that says
that every character has a destiny and
those that choose to run towards it will
go on that path whereas others that turn
their back on it will avoid it
Ray's father clearly did this and spent
the majority of his life on the run from
his father's wishes this pretty much
ties into the overall aspect of family
and destiny that is rampant throughout
the movie which I'm gonna be discussing
throughout this video we'll get into
that in just a bit though and we learn
that Palpatine has likely been
controlling Snoke and sending out
duplicates and this is why the scars on
the carried his head looks slightly
different in the force awakens to
how they do in the last Jedi I may I may
just be giving JJ a bit too much credit
there but yeah
that's just what I thought retro
actively he's been behind everything
controlling it all from the shadows
which yeah in my opinion lazy and
desperate writing the opening crawled
kind of tries to cram this all in in one
go to make it feel like it had some
setup but I think it's clear that
Palpatine was never really supposed to
be a part of this trilogy another thing
that they don't really explain is how
Luke's lightsaber was fixed after it was
torn into in the last Jedi we do know
however from behind the scenes images
that Rey used a binder to join the
pieces and this can be seen at certain
parts in the film such as when Leia Han
said Oba basically but basically it's
like tape when you break your spectacles
this picture on screen now is a visual
representation of JJ fixing Star Wars
and yet though a lot of things go and
explained those were kind of the two
main things that I saw people wondering
about so I just thought I'd cover them
here
now when the films are not blasting
through scenes in order for the
characters to go basically from item to
item in order to unearth the location of
EXA goal it's tackling identity and this
is seen throughout all of the main
characters finn is a stormtrooper turned
resistance hero and he finds kinship and
characters like jana who was stripped
away from their families though it's
never out and out stayed in the movie
originally it was revealed in the
supplementary material and leaks that
Lando was afar there and that the two
was separated on persona by the first
order the former remained on the planet
living an almost hermit lifestyle
whereas Jana was forced into combat
before she eventually put her arms down
and proceeded to fight back the two
don't out and I would say it but from
the leaks and their dialogue I think we
can draw the conclusion here mirroring
this poe is trying to hide from his past
not really accepting that he used to be
a spice runner
however after he reconnects with someone
that he used to do jobs with he seems
much more accepting what he's been
through and how it shaped him into the
person that he now is Huck's
is a spy working within the first order
c-3po loses his memory and now he
eventually gets it back
he's a quote-unquote death scene it does
feel like we're losing a big part of
what made him well him above all list
though the true conflict of identity
comes with both our two main players Rey
and Ren or reloj if you were into that
kind of thing who tackle with the
duality of their
personalities throughout the majority of
the film since killing his father Wren
has been torn between the light and dark
side and though he tends to be a more
towards the latter trying to turn rheya
every chance he gets it's actually he
you ends up swaying back to the light
this comes during the battle with Ray on
the Death Star to wreckage in which his
mother dies whilst trying to reach out
to him one more time
this distracts him long enough that Ray
is able to stab him steal his ship and
head to act you bless you to cut herself
off from the force left stranded
han Solo appears and the two pretty much
had the conversation that they had on
the bridge except this time it has the
added weight for Ren that he has lost
all of his family the ones he cared
about and that it's foolish to continue
on this dark path especially when he
cares for ray it's probably the best
part of the film and I doubt that anyone
had any trouble with seeing Han return
and change his son in the way that he so
desperately wanted to in the force
awakens this could have very easily been
a turn like Daenerys in season 8 of Game
of Thrones but thankfully at least this
moment is well paced and has gravitas
mirroring this ray who throughout the
entire trilogy has been desperate to
find a family really goes on a journey
this time to try and reconnect with the
roots and discover who she really is
there's even a point in the movie where
she gets asked her name and though I was
hoping she'd turn around and say bond
James Bond it's clear that she's torn
apart by not really knowing it's very
much a case of be careful what you wish
for though as she learns probably at the
midpoint of the movie that she's a
Palpatine and that the emperor has been
hunting her throughout her life in order
to bestow upon her what he sees as her
birthright she's confronted by a dark
version of herself that easily best sir
and at several points during the movie
she gives in to anger and rage using
force lightning at one point and also
force pushing thin he had something to
tell her but I don't I don't know what
it was because we'll never find out that
was a really really stupid thing to say
that in the movie anyway
after jumping through hoops to get to X
eagle ray finally comes face to face
with her grandfather
almost a husk he has the entirety of the
Sith living through him and once ready
to participate in the ritual of striking
him down this will cause the Sith and
Palpatine to inhabit air and as the new
Empress Palpatine would still makes me
laugh a bit when I say she will rule a
galaxy
at this point Ben has become
Jedi again and he helps her in the
finale which send us on the to tackling
Palpatine whilst the resistance fleet
fights the final order
there's cameos from wedge and almost an
on your left moment from Lando that
copies the Avengers end game a bit
shamelessly but will not talk about that
at the center of it all though is race
battle between a family and which choice
to make does she turn to the light
possibly dooming her friends or accept
that she is the new one true emperor now
you don't have to be a genius to know
which option she goes with but
unwittingly due to their force bond rey
and ren combined have enough power that
their life force rejuvenates the emperor
when tapped into ren tries to fight back
but it's cast aside but Rey stands
strong and through the Jedi who knew
family that now lived within her she
manages to fight back the Jedi most
notably Luke and Leia knew her true
identity but they still trusted that she
could bring balance to the force and
decided to train her anyway trusting in
her in the same way that Yoda and
obi-wan trusted in Luke now they could
have cast him at the side because he was
a Skywalker but yeah they saw that she
was a Palpatine and decided hey maybe
not everyone is controlled by destiny
she's able to destroy Palpatine and
doing the old reflect the Lightning back
with a lightsaber trick and the fleet
destroyed the final order saving the
galaxy this has a massive cost on Rey
and it actually kills her
however kylo is still alive and he gives
up all of his life force in order to
force heal her we've seen this tease
through the Mandalorian recently and
also throughout the movie and this use
of the force in a positive way allows
her to come back to life the two share a
kiss and then Ben dies fading away like
the Jedi do when they pass away with
everyone defeated and the galaxy back in
harmony Rey journeys to Tatooine most
notably luke's home where she buries not
only his lightsaber but layers as well i
kind of saw this as a closing of the
book and a visual representation of the
past finally being buried which was a
big plot motif of the last Jedi a
passerby who just happens to be in the
scene says no one's visited there for a
long time and she asks who she is
Rey pauses and looks out into the
distance where Luke and Leia appear as
force ghosts and she answers Rey
Skywalker I took this as her finally
accepting her identity and show
her allegiances and who our true family
are her father's a great example of this
and just because you born to a certain
family it doesn't make you tied to it
you can choose your own destiny she also
sparks up a yellow lightsaber which is
the first time that I think we've seen
one in a Star Wars film but yet don't
quote me on that there was a lot of them
during a tag of the clones however I do
think this holds some significance and
yellow for me has symbolism as its a mix
between green and red and this shows
that Rey has both accepted hoursit
lineage and the Jedi side of her which
could be a nod to Luke scream lightsaber
and I took this as her finally putting
in stone who she really is
she stares out onto the twin sunset of
the planet finally knowing who she is
and yet either way you look at it a
Palpatine still rules the galaxy hum
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay so what did I think of the movie
overall well what a mess from the
opening crawl all the way to the end
this film feels like a solid pit of
death sucking all the goodwill that I
had for the franchise and digesting it
slowly over thousands of years in the
most painful way possible the movie just
reeks of poor planning and Noah tried to
do a lot of course correction from the
last Jedi personally I think it may have
been better if they just went in that
direction instead of trying to write all
the wrongs of the prior movie and thus
not having enough time to develop their
own moments they tried to change things
so much that they all annoy fans of the
last Jedi and also people who hated the
last Jedi will be annoyed with how
underdeveloped this story is because it
tries to focus on new things so much
they just didn't set up any of this film
in the last movie so now that you have
to set it up as fast as possible and
because of this the pacing is so rushed
I don't know why there's been some big
things set in stone now where Star Wars
films have to be divided in two
trilogies because this needed a fourth
movie in order to tell a complete story
like remember when infinity war was
announced
everyone was like it'll be the end of
the Avengers trilogy however they
couldn't tell the full story in that
film
so guess what they just made another
movie which would have been the smart
thing to do here as well like you idiots
I think it's very obvious that Palpatine
wasn't supposed to be in this film and
there was even a lot of rumors that were
flying about that Matt Smith would be
the villain but I guess this was changed
in the reshoots the movie itself it just
it exemplifies all of the mistakes in
Lucasfilm there was no creative
direction from the off and because of
Kathleen Kennedy's lack of plan the
movie is all over the place they clearly
didn't have the foresight to map out all
the movies and now they're trying to use
a Wayfinder to get there this film
really suffers and whilst I don't think
it's as bad as the Phantom Menace or
even Attack of the Clones
as far as satisfying conclusions go this
is a complete dud this exemplifies the
difference between Marvel and Lucasfilm
you have Kevin Feige who has everything
planned out wealth or hour ahead of time
he lays the groundwork for it and then
Kathleen Kennedy who just makes it up as
she goes along yep it's just a mess it's
crazy to think that this is the end of
the trilogy and with the controversy
surrounding it the huge pot leaks and so
on I don't know how there's not going to
be a lot of firings in the next couple
of months so yeah very very
disappointing film and this is how Star
Wars dies to thunderous applause Disney
brought balance to the force
just not in the way that they expected
they tried to please everyone and
ultimately ended up pleasing no one and
that's why the movie gets a 5 out of 10
I actually think the last Jedi is better
like genuinely it's a much better movie
now obviously I love to hear your
thoughts on the rise of Skywalker so
make sure you leave them in the comment
section below and if you enjoyed this
video then force push that like button
if you want something stole ated that's
a lot better than this then make sure
you check out my full breakdown of the
Mandalorian episode 7 which we linked at
the end we go over all of the Easter
eggs and things you need to know about
the show so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come chat to me after the
video that make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey
or head over to my discord server which
be linked in the description below we
drop videos on there
so if you want to see stuff before
anyone else and that's the best place to
be it's free to join and we have an
awesome community so hope you see over
there very soon we're also giving away a
free copy of Joker which is one of our
favourite movies of the air and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video make she's
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the rise of Skywalker in the
comments section below
the one is gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of January in the set will be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best I'll see
you next time take care peace